a brand new WB Games job listing
indicates they are hiring for an
executive producer okay retro what's the
big deal I'm sure they hire executive
producers all the time well Hogwarts
Legacy fans let me walk you through why
it is a big deal and before we get too
far into this I got to give a shout out
to the one who found all of this Joe
mack one of our community members AKA
support Crow aka the Hogwarts Legacy mem
King himself that is where I saw the
very first mention of this job listing
all right so here's how it relates the
Hogwarts Legacy first of all they are
hiring two executive producers this job
is available in two locations one is
Burbank California and one is Salt Lake
City Utah Now by this point most of you
know the location of avalanche software
the developers of Hogwarts Legacy is
Salt Lake City Utah here's where we get
into the meat of it they are seeking an
executive producer to direct development
of games note the plural there based on
one of our most successful entertainment
franchises yes WB has a lot of
successful entertainment franchises
however remember this one is being
located in Salt Lake and at least in
recent memory I can't think of anything
more successful anything bigger than the
release of Hogwarts pyy it very well
could finish 2023 as the bestselling
game of the year which in a year that
has been just phenomenal for video games
that would be an incredible feat now the
next line the EP will have a chance to
partner with a talented and successful
development Studio that is building
their next generation of games talented
and successful development Studio I
think hch software certainly fits the
bill especially after their success with
Hogwarts Legacy all right all right I
know you're probably not convinced yet
let's read on MMO development wait what
and operations and open world RPG game
experience guys in the brief time that
I've had the opportunity to work and
interact with the folks at Avalanche and
the folks at WB I can say one thing for
certain they listen to their fans they
may not always be able to act on it they
may not always be able to do exactly
what we're hoping they can do however
they listen and in both the leadup to
Hogwarts Legacy and the aftermath of
Hogwarts Legacy the conversations that I
had with James of expecto go Andy
reloads wizard PhD Benjamin snow the
list goes on and on every time we have
gotten together to talk about this game
to talk about our reactions to it to
talk about what we hope to see next one
of the things that we always bring up is
a multiplayer mode a multiplayer
experience some way for us to be able to
play these types of games together and I
know that's not what everybody wants
however I think I figured out a way that
avalan and WP can satisfy both parties
so the way I look at it we have three
possibilities here for what this could
mean the third option is the one that I
hope to see and the one that would
probably please the most people but
first I want to start off with the
option that this is going to be a DLC
add-on mode for Hogwarts Legacy and the
closest example I can think of is if you
look at ghost of tsushima we talked
about this at length leading up to the
launch of Hogwart psychos yes it was
being developed as an open world action
RPG focused on single player only they
made that very clear but there was
always this nagging thought in the back
of my mind about yes I know that's true
however the Wizarding World one of the
things that it was built on is the
community the community of fans that
lined up for each book at midnight that
lined up to watch the movies at midnight
and that pre-ordered this game in
absolutely huge numbers how do we take
something they love and make it even
better well we put them all together and
let them experience it together and that
can only be done through something like
a multiplayer experience so if you're
not familiar with the co of tsushima
example it was a single player game
through and through however they kind of
did a surprise several months after the
launch of the game they just dropped
this online Cooperative multiplayer mode
which got rave reviews I mean people
love the main game and they also love
that add-on mode as well so if we kind
of play this example out here maybe the
folks at Avalanche have some ideas maybe
they've already started working on this
and now they just need someone with that
kind of overall MMO experience to come
in and sort of guide things now all that
being said I think this one is highly
unlikely I don't think this is what will
end up happening I mean like we were
talking about Hogwarts Legacy was
developed from the ground up as a single
player open world action RPG I do still
expect I know we're kind of getting late
and we're wondering is it actually going
to happen or not I do still think there
will be DLC for the game I mean at the
very least we know that the Haunted Hogs
me stuff is highly likely to land on
Xbox and P early next year and I feel
pretty strongly in saying that DLC was
absolutely in their plans at some point
however depending on the ideas that they
had for a DLC and I'm sure this is a
conversation that happens in every
Studio it's like do we put that in a DLC
or do we have enough here to let's just
make this the sequel let's put all of
this into the next game and say you know
what we had a great run with Hogwarts
Legacy now we're ready to move to the
sequel obviously all that is still to be
determined if I had to bet money right
now I would say yes a DLC for this game
not multiplayer not MMO is still coming
however I'm not as convinced as I was a
few months ago all right so the number
two possibility here is that this is for
the Hogwarts legacy sequel maybe they
have decided not to do a Hogwarts Legacy
2 as everybody was expecting in just
another open world single player action
RPG maybe they've decided you know what
we've heard the fans we've heard those
folks out there who talk about how much
they want to experience this world
together how much they want to be able
to play with their friends and go out on
missions with their friends now if that
is something that has resonated there
with the team at Avalanche then maybe
they're saying let's go for it let's
bring someone in who has this MMO
experience and see if we can make this
thing happen that being said I think
this is also an unlikely option as much
as Avalanche and the folks at WB know we
want some sort of console PC MMO that we
can all play together I also think they
know that there are a very large number
of people out there who want that single
player contained experience you know in
the leadup to the launch of Hogwarts
Legacy I heard from so many of you guys
in the comments saying saying no I don't
want multiplayer just as many as I heard
from people saying yes I do want
multiplayer and then you have people
like me that are kind of just in the
middle I enjoy both I think they're both
awesome but seeing the incredible
success of this game this Standalone
Hogwart py single player nothing else I
think they'd be crazy and I think WB
knows they'd be crazy not to follow up
on that and do something in a very
similar style so where does that leave
us then that leaves us with number three
and what is probably the most likely
option but I think also the most
exciting option
and that is a brand new Wizarding World
game that would be developed from the
ground up as a Wizarding World MMO yes I
said it folks I'm allowing my mind to go
there for just a bit just a small Ray of
Hope that they might actually be trying
to make this happen alongside a
fully-fledged Hogwarts Legacy 2o
Hogwarts Legacy if you miss this made a
ton of money a ton of money and as crazy
as things have been in the game industry
we've seen so many lay playoffs we have
not seen that happen very very
fortunately we have not seen that happen
at Avalanche we've actually seen them
hiring and adding to their team it's not
just for this job I had a video a few
months back that strongly indicated they
were hiring for people to work on
Hogwarts Legacy 2 even though they
weren't calling it Hogwarts Legacy 2 it
really seemed like they were hiring more
people to work on the next big thing for
them I mean to be honest with you guys
this game made so much money that if
they wanted to they could open a second
division of avalanche I would think you
know we see this with some of the big
studios like naughty dog and Rockstar it
could be in a completely different
location it could also be located in
Salt Lake I'm not sure the exact
physical size of their space there if
they have enough room to add that many
team members I've said this for a while
now if I were WB after the success of
this game I would go to Avalanche and
say what do you guys want to make next
and what can we do to help make it
happen now if we go back to even before
the game launched we know game director
Allan 2 talked about they want to tell
more stories in this world I've seen
nothing to indicate that that has
changed so I do expect they want to
follow up with a Hogwarts Legacy 2 now
it's also important to remember that
Avalanche doesn't own the right to do a
Hogwarts game WB owns the right to do
that so WB is the publisher here
Avalanche is the developer along with
Port key games which I think very often
people kind of leave them out because
it's not as clear exactly what port key
games does and how they factor into this
so WB could just as easily give this to
another one of their mini Studios and
say hey Avalanche you guys work on
Hogwarts Legacy 2 open world single
player action RPG go for it then we're
going to let this new studio we're going
to let them focus on working on a
Hogwarts MMO a Wizarding World MMO but
the big curveball in that theory is that
one of these executive producer jobs is
being located in Salt Lake the very
place where Avalanche software resides
oh man I I really don't know what do you
guys think let me know in the comments
below who knows maybe it's nothing at
all as always thank you all so much for
watching I'll talk to you again
soon